as a production designer what are some
of the first few things you do when you
first sign on the job when I first
signed on to a job or I've usually read
the script and met with the director so
those were the preliminary things and
often when I if it's a director I
haven't worked with before I make a
presentation to show them of at my
meeting my first meeting with them
before I have the job of my sort of
visual concept for the movie and with
Todd I've worked with Todd before so I
didn't have to do that and so when I met
with should I talk about when I met with
Todd specific or you can I met with Todd
specifically it was myself and Ed
lachman the cinematographer who I've
worked with before and Sandy Powell the
costume designer and we all met in New
York where I live and Todd kind of we
had a long discussion about the general
feeling that he was trying to go for in
Carroll and we talked a lot about the
period of 1952 in New York City and how
it wasn't really the bright sunny 1950s
that people usually think of mid-century
modern period but it was this darker
post-war period so that was one of the
most important things we talked about
and then we talked about saul leiter the
photographer and some other
photographers who had been photographing
New York at that time and the looks that
they had achieved in their photographs
and how we were going to emulate some of
their elements in the look of the movie
and from there there's a few things that
I do when I start a movie and they're
sort of it going on at the same time I
start location scouting and that's a
huge part of the movies I work on
because and some of them have very big
builds but they always have a lot of
locations and and at the same time I'm
assembling a wall a big wall of visual
reference that sort of shows what I
think is the look of the movie and of
research the specific research so for a
period movie there's a lot of specific
research that has to be done what color
were fire hydrants in New York in 1952
they were black by the way but I didn't
know that so this is the kind of thing
that you know it's
all this trivia but you have to know it
to make a realistic looking movie so you
have the visual reference and the
research and the third thing that is
important for the beginning of my
process is to have is to figure out the
color palette of the movie so I myself
have a large collection of vintage paint
decks undone paint chips and I bring
that to every movie i work on naughty
not just period once and so we looked at
the paint chips from the 40s on the 30s
and the early 50s and picked out a sort
of range of colors that we wanted to
work with and then I had my charge
scenic Pat's brought who came with me
from New York to Cincinnati do a lot of
color samples to buy for two by two
color samples which we lined up around
the room and at the same time I set
decorator Heather leffler was getting
fabric samples that we matched with the
color samples so we sort of had at
reza's apartment section on a carol's
house section and all the different
motels section and the toy store so
we're kind of creating little pieces of
all the different worlds that you can
actually walk into the art department
and and get an idea of what the movie is
going to look like in the in the sense
of the color palette
you